my name is Heidi Akoo bian and I am a
junior art major here at Hillsdale
College tonight I will be introducing
our guest speaker
Roger W Robinson Jr mr. Robinson is
president and CEO of our WR Advisory
Group a risk management software and
open source intelligence firm he is also
co-founder and chairman of the proc
security studies institute in the Czech
Republic mr. Robinson earned a BA from
Duke University and an MA from George
Washington University he served a senior
director of international economic
affairs on Ronald Reagan's national
security council where he was the
principal architect of the secret
economic and financial strategy that was
a key component of efforts that led to
the demise of the Soviet Union he later
served as chairman of the Congressional
us-china economic and security review
commission prior to his government
service he was a vice president in the
International Department of Chase
Manhattan Bank with responsibility for
loan portfolios in the USSR Central and
Eastern Europe and Yugoslavia everyone
please join me in welcoming mr. Robinson
to the school
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I want to start by thanking Larry
Arndt and all of his colleagues at
Hillsdale for this special opportunity
to be with you tonight and address this
esteem CCA event I also want to give
special thanks to Kim Ellsworth and Matt
Bell I took the tour today Abele
executed by Nathan layman it was an
experience and I just couldn't be more
delighted to be with you tonight and I
apologize in advance in the sense that
I'm going to give you a fire hose of
information much of it new and original
and time is a bit tight so I'm going to
be jumping right in if I may I apologize
for a little bit of a cough but we'll
try to push through that you know before
we turn to what is clearly China's
economic and financial warfare strategy
being waged against us and I'll explain
the components many of which you know
some of which you won't know until we're
done I want to get into just an earlier
episode that was alluded to in the
introduction namely the true story of
the Soviet Union's effort to almost
succeed in continuing to keep itself a
going concern by living off of the west
ball off of us and muddling through to
this very day all of which was brought
to a screeching halt by a president
named Ronald Reagan and his national
security adviser and best friend William
P Clark who I had the privilege of
serving under and as mentioned I had
been with Chase Bank as vice president
division executive for the u.s. USSR a
sorry the USSR Eastern Europe division
of
Bank and in that capacity you can
imagine it was my job to know where the
money was because after all as a banker
you're trying to gauge creditworthiness
and so what I came to realize is
something I brought to the White House
to the NSC which was that these people
these folks had no money or what they
did have was largely from us and let me
give you some numbers when I went to the
National Security Council in the
beginning of 1982 Soviet total hard
currency income was approximately 32
billion dollars a year which was one
third of the annual revenues of General
Motors and Exxon at the time so you have
an empire stretching from Havana to
Hanoi that is the equivalent of the
revenues of one third of one American
company and it was that kind of
circumstance that we were looking at and
other what what I would call
life-support tubes that were keeping
them going notably loan arrangements I
mean the Soviets were spending about 16
billion dollars more than they were
making all of that 16 billion dollar gap
was being financed by Western
governments and banks
we weren't funding you know ten percent
or something like that but when you look
about 60 when you think about sixteen
billion coincidentally that was the
approximate cost in hard currency
remembering that the ruble is
non-convertible that was the cost of the
external Soviet empire everything
outside of the Soviet Union itself was
totaling about sixteen billion
so you can imagine President Reagan who
always believed that the Soviets were
terribly vulnerable economically to
learn that we the West were financing a
hundred percent of the external empire
it's that kind of thing those kind of
numbers that he was looking for all this
time he knew that they had no
entrepreneurship that they had no
technological dynamism that they had no
none of the freedoms that you need to
have a functioning free market economy
this was all an administered command
Aventis all of you know fraught with
rigidities and so this really came as a
surprise the Europeans on the other hand
had a completely different philosophy
they believed in auspi leety as the
Germans call it which is the commercial
bridge-building would lead inevitably to
greater geopolitical cooperation gee I
wonder where we've heard that before
you know China right we were supposed to
buy into the notion that if we just gave
them WTO and we gave them our technology
and we gave them our money and access to
our capital markets and trade markets
that they too would come around to a
political accommodation and give their
people more freedom and have a safer
more secure world with us obviously
didn't happen the same was true with
Soviet day tante the Nixon Kissinger
period what did they do with those
credits what did they do with that
technology of course they used it all
against us and to make themselves
stronger to expand their empire and to
basically continue to engage in
nefarious activities and so here we go
again so basically where we drew the
line was on a project called the
Siberian gas pipeline project it was
a two or twin strand huge pipeline 3,600
miles from Siberia into the West
European gas grid it was going to be the
centerpiece of their future hard
currency earning structure for them it
was a magnificent twofer dependency of
Western Europe on natural gas would soar
to over 70 75 percent minimum and they
would nearly double that anemic 32
billion figure with just one deal and
this is in the midst of their massing
troops on the Polish border to invade
the moment that they learned that
general euros else key was not going to
suppress solidarity he was not going to
silence John Paul the second that he was
going to declare martial law or we would
have yet another Soviet style invasion
tanks and all so it's in this window
that the largest deal in east-west
economic history was going down not only
was it going down but was going down on
taxpayer subsidized terms the Soviets
were viewed as a less developed country
worthy of below market interest rates in
Germany France others were too happy to
accommodate because for the Germans
you know they had 19 million hostages on
the other side of the wall I mean for
them this was a protection racket they
wanted to pay off the Soviets so that
they would have better care of their
people that keep the peace at all at all
costs
you know throw steak in the cage of the
bear and keep it mollified now France
was no better in this regard so the
president had a decision to make we had
a monopoly on oil and gas equipment and
technology that could go through
permafrost we got it from the North
Slope nobody else in the world had it at
the time so we use that monopoly
to basically take the side of our polish
friends and try to penalize the Soviets
for massing these troops and threatening
yet another invasion far from doing the
biggest deal in east-west history the
president was dedicated to stopping it
and appropriately so so basically we
declared oil and gas equipment sanctions
those contracts were picked up by the
Europeans who were selling the same
equipment but under our licenses now
this is kind of a long story too long
for tonight because I want to transition
over to China as quickly as we can but
we need to understand that this
disconnect with Europe then and now with
Russia was a blood on the floor
estrangement at the time I mean we had
to at one point close the US market
entirely to those European companies
that continue to ship to the Soviet
Siberian gas pipeline over our
objections and we had to give them a
choice you're gonna do business with the
Soviet Union or the United States but
you're not going to do business with
both well four of the six companies that
we took imposed import controls against
as they're called went under within six
months and about 250,000 people went
into the street unemployed Europe got
the picture and the epilogue of this
story in short is that we put a cap on
Soviet gas deliveries to Western Europe
at 30% of total supplies period we ended
the subsidized credits in fact we helped
dry up the provision of credits by
Western governments and banks altogether
we went to the Saudis secretly
to have them pump two million barrels
more oil a day and decontrol prices at
the wellhead here knocking oil prices
down to $10 a barrel knowing that for
every dollar drop in the price of a
barrel of oil
the Soviets lost 500 million to a
billion dollars per dollar right this is
on that anemic number that I was talking
about
so the strategy for the takedown of the
Soviet Union was a secret one but
nothing was more secret than the
economic and financial peace there were
maximum 13 people in the country that
knew about this strategy because our
fear was that if the Soviet Union
understood what we were about there and
they started to see their demise loom
too large it could be use it or lose at
time as we say on the nuclear trade back
up against the wall the whole thing so
ironically you'd think that the
political military is always the more
secret components wrong it's about the
money it's about economics and Finance
then and now so with that oh and you
know we're looking at North stream 2
today the president's calling Germany a
captive nation to Russia today when the
dependency levels about 35% how would we
be feeling if that number was 80 percent
which it would have been had there not
been a Reagan and a Clark and to the
extent that I was able to play a role in
that it's been a privilege all my life
so that's a little bit of the epilogue
that we're looking at and it is relevant
to the China story because the Soviets
if you think about it we're doing
something rather unique they were using
natural gas as a weapon there was no
such thing as pipeline politics like
there is today
they had never used natural gas as a
weapon before to leverage NATO and cause
those divisions in the Alliance that are
so debilitating we thought and had to
speculate that if they had the power
they would use it Europe didn't think so
they thought that my gosh you know if
the Soviet Union shows itself not to be
a reliable supplier that's crazed I mean
that's just not going to happen of
course they were wrong as to history's
proven when they could use now ask
Ukraine ask the Baltic States ask
anybody who's ever crossed the Soviets
and and the Russians today they're using
natural gas routinely as a weapon so who
would have thought that literally
underground on the subterranean basis
the tentacles of our demise were being
delivered today that those tentacles are
China in our capital markets now I'll
get to that story in a moment let's talk
about China's economic and financial
warfare against us for just a moment
here you know about belton road
obviously a strategic wildly ambitious
undertaking to wrap up huge segments of
the world on their terms you know about
China 2025 where they're trying to
dominate the key technology sectors
everything from artificial intelligence
quantum computing you name it and
they're trying to get there first
5g you read about these things the
forced technology transfer we know about
the predatory trade practices you know
about the president brought these things
to the forefront after countless
presidents let it slide and he's to be
given credit for that
the tariff war is a good thing in the
sense that we've got to take a stand
mm-hmm but these are things you know
here's something you don't know
China has something over 700 companies
in our stock and bond markets our
so-called capital markets they've got
about 86 companies in the New York Stock
Exchange about 62 and Nasdaq and over
500 in the over-the-counter market this
very murky poorly regulated market of
course they gravitate to something
that's non transparent and the most
lacks regulatory regime all good police
states do that and among those 700
companies we have some of the most
egregious bad actors who've been
committing national security abuses
against our country the same with human
rights abuses I mean companies like
hikvision that is responsible for the
facial recognition technology and the
surveillance cameras that are placed
along the walls every few meters of the
concentration camps holding 1 to 2
million we Gore's religious minorities
in Shin Jon gee I wonder if we had in
mind helping finance concentration camps
with our retirement dollars and our
investment accounts most of the people
in this room are I know that that sounds
wild but that's an empirical fact in my
view if we take you know that statement
as it is the majority of you unwittingly
of course because we have no screening
mechanism in the United States never
have for our capital markets I don't
know how big they are around 40 to 60
trillion a funds under management or so
look it's not the same true that's not
true betrayed we've got the Committee on
Foreign Investment in the United States
we just strengthened it further with the
so-called firma legislation we're
worried about Chinese coming in there
and trying to take our high technology
companies to try to position themselves
right next to our military bases in
other words anything they can do we've
got to be scrutinizing this and we've
belatedly woken up and are doing so now
belatedly well what about the money
completely unprotected do we really
think the SEC is screening Chinese
companies for a litany of their past
national security abuses if they are
they're doing a pretty poor job because
there are repeat sanctions violators
there are proliferators of weapons of
mass destruction and ballistic missiles
there are advanced weapons manufacturers
for the People's Liberation Army there
are South China Sea Island builders and
militarize errs their company's
underwriting
the North Korean threat there are known
hackers we know who they are they're
here in our capital markets there are
companies accused of espionage that have
been indicted or had their employees
indicted do you find any of this in the
risk section of the prospectuses are any
of you hearing about this from your
financial planners and your fund
managers I mean have you ever seen one
risk communicated to you of who these
folks really are and who their network
of subsidiaries are no not a word not
one of you ever have you ever heard this
topic discussed before at a cocktail
party much less on
television a think tank session a
session like the one we're having now
guess what there's not been one
interagency meeting in the executive
branch there's not been one hearing in
the Congress ever now what does that
tell you what it should tell you is the
China wants us to concentrate on this
little shiny object over here called
trade they can do tariffs all day long I
mean they're not it's hurting them which
is a good thing but not that badly in
other words I'm talking tonight about
what they never want you to see what
they desperately need is the dollars I
mean they have practically a trillion
dollars of exposure in our Markus we
don't even know how much because they've
got dollar denominated bonds our
currency being issued in Hong Kong
Frankfurt Singapore well guess where
they're ending up in your bond
portfolios because our investment banks
buy them from overseas to get around the
loopholes of regulatory regimes and in
they come in the secondary market so we
don't even know what our exposure to
China is but I can tell you this in the
next thirty six months it'll be about
two to three trillion more than it is
today I mean they are moving as fast as
they can into your portfolios I don't
know how many people in America are in
the capital markets let me give you a
rough guess 150 million hundred eighty
million of us you know older folks chil
babies you know the Gerber program I
mean this is all stocks and bonds right
so what if we wake up one morning and we
find out 14 17 22 percent of our
retirement accounts are
in Chinese securities now that may seem
far-fetched to you
I suggest you that's what's gonna happen
and that's soon
now when that happens if it does I pray
it doesn't but you know these are trends
that are pretty clear I mean goldman
sachs and others are the ones that are
predicting this at least on the numbers
you know on how much is coming in well
then the Chinese have figured out that
all of these scores of millions of
Americans have a vested financial
interest in opposing any future
sanctions against them in opposing any
penalties whatsoever against them
irrespective of the severity of the
offenses that's called checkmate
ladies and gentlemen that's called an
excess exponential increase in the scale
of the so-called China Lobby we think
that the China Lobby is very formidable
today Lord knows it is that's kitty cars
next to where we're headed and we are
it's not talked about we're not seeing
it any more than we saw the subterranean
natural gas strangling our European
allies and undermining the structure of
NATO so here we go again another unseen
villain in the economic and financial
portfolio I mean let me give you a live
happening right now
event well first I should say that it's
even the case that China's sovereign
bonds are here that Russia has sovereign
bonds here when I say sovereign bonds I
mean these are bonds initiated by the
government
you know member our Liberty Bonds during
World War two I mean we used to finance
our war effort with bonds which the
government of course can use it their
sole discretion well now our our
countrymen are buying Chinese and
Russian bonds to destroy our liberties I
mean do you know that CalPERS owns four
hundred and sixty million in Russian
sovereign bonds by itself just do the
math as to what the other 50 states have
I mean when we talk about the 50 states
we've looked at probably 20 of those
states they're littered with Chinese bad
actors of the type that I've described
when you look at university endowments
and College endowments same I mean
University of Michigan for example has
44 percent of its 12.2 billion in assets
in private equity and venture capital
it's a new big shift in that direction
from University of Michigan of the
venture capital portion one-third or
Chinese now I chose a local example and
it's not like I'm trying to excoriate
University of Michigan I'm not this
could be any of us that's the problem I
mean I'm not here to point fingers at
them because again where's the
disclosure but also I have to I have to
say they're not they're not blame free
where's their diligence I mean they have
all kinds of rules and standards and
governance that that on paper say that
they're not going to be financing
concentration camps and they're not
going to be funding and underwriting the
People's Liberation Army and folks like
that
or folks engaged in espionage and US
sanctions violations I mean really but
it's happening so we have a problem in
the 50 states let me tell you state
legislatures need to take this up ASAP
so that's where we sit now take your
live example now this is private capital
for the most part we're talking about
let's talk about our taxpayer money you
know for the longest time the federal
Thrift Savings Plan at this country
which is you know the roots federal
retirement system for all federal
employees all members of the military
the cabinet the Congress the Joint
Chiefs our combatant commanders our
fighting men and women are all relying
on the Thrift Savings Plan 578 billion
the biggest in the country that I know
of CalPERS is 370 that's the biggest
pension fund but this is bigger 5.7
million people not surprising are
covered so I was checking on them well
for the longest time they were doing the
right thing they would find out they
they have an international portfolio
it's 50 billion for the longest time
they were using in index the Morgan
Stanley capital investment has a whole
range of indexes but this one was
developed countries largely
industrialized democracies well okay
international exposure diversification
all that's not a bad thing but guess
what in November December of 2017 they
had the bright idea of making a change
they wanted to capture those yields of
the emerging markets so they hired a
consulting firm
an investment consultant from Wall
Street and said we want to expand the
universe of companies we can own
internationally
well they said fine have we got a deal
for you
the Morgan Stanley the MSCI all country
world index well that includes China and
I know for a fact that it includes
many of these egregious bad actors I
could name them I mean we're talking
about companies like Avik that's PLA
they make fighter aircraft I mean we're
talking about some of these indexes
honed on China's shipbuilding they make
ballistic missile submarines targeting
our cities and the list goes on not to
mention again the facial recognition and
surveillance state
this digital totalitarian police state
innovation in their minds well I don't
think we have a mind financing that kind
of innovation for China right not with
our money so this is going to be
implemented and by the way that's going
to be all of the international portfolio
it's not like you're gonna have a choice
if you have any international exposure
you're in the MSCI all country world
index and you own China automatically
and the bad actors there too this goes
into effect in 2020 right around the
corner the decisions already made yet
it's not been implemented we've got to
reverse that decision either that or
Nancy Pelosi who cares deeply about the
tibetans with her money is going to be
financing or is going to own a company
that hat is doing the facial recognition
technology to be able to pick up the
tibetans at train stations and
incarcerate them again the same with the
we Gore's
any champion of human rights is going to
be violating their sacred values the
Joint Chiefs of Staff our combat and
commanders our Secretary of Defense
they're going to be underwriting the
militarization of the illegal islands in
the South China Sea not conceptually
with their retirement dollars the
secretary of state of the United States
if he has international exposure he's
going to be financing multiple US
sanctions violators gee that'll go down
well politically so if we can't stop
this ladies and gentlemen we're in a
very very bad way you know we can lose
this thing to China I mean they have no
cushion there are a lot more frail and
weak than we think but again like the
Soviets if we keep these life-support
tubes pumping we're going to finance our
way out of our freedoms out of our way
of life and out of everything we hold
dear it's the money it was the money on
the Soviets it's the money on China
that's what they don't want you to know
if you go and ask your fund manager your
financial planner gee do I own China I
mean do I own Chinese companies they're
gonna look at you quizzically and
probably say you know I don't really
know and if you ask well what kind of
Chinese companies I mean if you guys
looked at the of the parent companies
and their subsidiaries and do they have
a track record of national security and
human rights abuses you're gonna have a
blank stare coming back no way you're
gonna get that answer what does that
tell you I'm telling you there you're
not gonna answer the question so you
tell me what that says about the state
of play in your own lives
and the life of our nation so our
detractors of arguments like mine are
saying well this guy Robinson and people
like him I mean they're going to they're
gonna be there they're their views are
detrimental to the free flow of global
capital they're trying to contract our
investable universe they're trying to
narrow what we can own and what we can
buy as we try to get a better yield
they're gonna say we're politicizing the
markets you know what's it going to be
next to backhoe guns you know they're
comparing national security and human
rights to socially responsible investing
these are preferences these are material
risks they are undisclosed that's
legally actionable it's called
material risk omission you're not
allowed to do that
that's what class-action lawsuits are
made of and that's by the way one of the
directions were going to go now I could
give you and then maybe in the Q&A some
ideas about what we can do but let me
give you I've given you a lot of bad
news let me give you some good news kind
of and it is good news we dominate the
economic and financial domain on the
planet Earth our capital markets are
roughly the size of the rest of the
world's combined you know one could say
if we're making it difficult for China
they're just gonna go to another
exchange somewhere else and we're just
gonna be the ones left out of those fees
of course this is what Wall Street's
thinking there's nowhere else to go
nobody has the depth and volume of our
markets yeah China's needs $4 are so
voracious that they would use up the
volume and a frankfurter or a London
months maybe there's only us you know we
had that oil and gas equipment and
technology monopoly during the Soviet
days because of North Slope guess what
our near monopoly is today we have all
the money there playing in our sandbox
we're not playing in theirs these guys
are waging economic and financial
warfare against us we're not only not on
the field but we're not even at the
stadium now President Trump is trying to
put us there on the field on trade but
China is ok with that you can throw them
into that briar patch you don't see you
won't see any kind of gamesmanship on
the money that's what they don't want us
to know so it is within our power to
take action here and all I can say is
and I want to leave time for questions
we just have to remember both as
taxpayers and individuals you know this
is our money and we don't have to play
I mean article 7 of the National
Intelligence law of China allows every
single entity commercial entity every
enterprise to be weaponized instantly if
Beijing orders itself to commit
espionage technology theft anything they
need that's a matter of record
that's public ok so for those that don't
want to try to differentiate good
Chinese from bad Chinese meaning
seemingly commercial benign companies
from bad actors who have a track record
of doing
egregious harm one solution is to say no
China well that's a fairly
straightforward message that a fund
manager or a financial planner can that
could penetrate any way we're playing
the game here and trying to do this in a
constructive way if you look at market
principles and when you're talking to
the Wall Street types and when you're
talking to forty to sixty trillion
dollars of funds under management if we
go with outrage in our hearts about
these you know how could this be
and how could you do this it's
unpatriotic it's not the right thing
you're undermining our country's our
values our moral compass do you know
what you're going to get from Wall
Street a big yawn but if we go to them
and say where's the risk management
where's the disclosure where's the
transparency
where's the good governance where's the
preservation of share value and
corporate reputation and brand well
that's a lot more uncomfortable because
that's their lingo and they can't ignore
that I mean the SEC is again supposed to
demand the disclosure of material risk
you know they don't consider national
security abuses and human rights abuses
of the scale I'm talking about as
material risks and yet there's example
after example of Chinese companies whose
stock tanked as soon as this press
became available on for example the
surveillance camera cameras on the
concentration camps their stock fell I
mean that's what a material risk is all
about so it's not as though I'm asking
for the world here and we can ask for
enhanced disclosure for goodness sake I
mean how minimis and how benign does
that sound to you it almost makes me
seem like I'm not a Siri
sky except there is one small kicker the
Chinese aren't disclosing anything
they're not going to acknowledge these
risks they're not going to acknowledge
disputes they're not going to
acknowledge a history of wrongdoing
because if they do literally or
figuratively they're taken out in a shot
back in Beijing again figuratively
perhaps lose your job I don't know what
it may be but you're not going to see
folks volunteering to make such
disclosures and I've got an example or
two for people that want to hear about
what disclosure can do so we have the
tools and we've got the enforcement of
market principles we don't have to say
hey we want all Chinese excise from our
markets we want sanctions we want market
closure select market closure we don't
have to do that of course that's when
they argue oh my gosh you know the sky's
gonna fall no no let's just go for the
enforcement of market principles and
then see what they say because when they
say they're not going to engage in
enhance disclosure that tells you all
you need to know what are they hiding
it's that old refrain huh so I want to
leave time for questions but again this
is our money and it is these these
trillions are not going to be funneled
for the demise of our country the
gutting of our values the destruction of
all we hold dear not on my watch and not
on your watch thank you
please Thank You mr. Robinson we now
have time for a few questions please
make your way to the microphone if you
have a question thank you Morgan Stanley
Capital Index and investment I think is
but it's yes it's the Morgan Stanley
Index huh that's right Morgan Stanley we
know Capital Group owns American Funds
be careful right
I'm not sure I quite deciphered that but
ah okay well it might be a nice touch if
they engage in some diligence and
protect the American investor from
material risks to share value in
corporate reputation that's my answer we
have a question to the speakers right
thank you for patient it's the first
actionable thing I've heard at this
conference and I'd like to do something
so do you have a roadmap of what you
just commented on that I can follow with
my investment counselor to get you know
change at least in my portfolio relative
what you're talking about we are working
on it this has been such an intense
three years of research and if you can
believe it
this little Prague Security Studies
Institute of mine and our to be frank
our private sector company as well
we're the only think tank in the world
that's pursuing that I know of that's
pursuing this issue I mean think about
that so you can imagine that our
bandwidth is just stretched to the max
so we want to be able to service just
this kind of need we are developing a
list of on the private sector side of
Chinese bad actors and we're way down
the road in successfully doing that a
track record a risk profile for all of
these guys and what they and their
subsidiaries have done in these two
material risk categories of national
security and human rights so that's
going to be something that would be
available and we're looking into again
the 50 states the university endowments
right now we're researching the official
US sanctions list to find out how many
action companies are in our markets
we're looking at the entity list of the
commerce department same purpose in
other words how widespread is this
problem it's a little bit like trying to
detect what what level of metastasize
ation do we have going on here if you
want to use the cancer analogy so the
answer is we're working hard now and
will be in we can be in touch to be sure
as to helping you be better informed
about the questions specific questions
that you want to be asking if you you
know and also to search your own
portfolio to find out where are going to
be the problem areas I mean it's not
just MSCI the footsie Russell index in
June they bought 1097 Chinese companies
right out of the mainland Shenzhen and
Shanghai exchanges and added them to
their their emerging market index how
many of those are bad actors we know
several we've already done the research
on that Bloomberg Barclays aggregate
global index I think it's called 54
trillion of funds under management
they're buying Chinese sovereign bonds
and Chinese bank and corporate bonds and
adding those to its index as they say
S&P is following suit this is the new
big thing so the index providers are the
are the inscrutable but most problematic
because when they buy it's viral I mean
they're infecting every healthy cell of
the American body politic overnight so
when folks are buying Chinese companies
left and right in over a thousand in a
shot you know
you are picking up all kinds of
egregious players so we'll work with you
best we can and anybody else here in
trying to give you the tools that you
need and we're trying to develop those
tools as quickly as we can I mean we've
been concentrating on trying to get the
scope of the problem but now it's time
to worry about the solution set so thank
you okay well there's two ways you can
contact I mean this isn't to be an
advertisement but rwr advisory com is is
the corporate side PSSI dot cz is the
think-tank side we're trying to do some
research and we're trying to do the
activist piece on the think-tank side so
I would say that we're good to go within
the next 60 days so and I you know the
folks here at Hillsdale can give you our
contact info and we will answer these
questions directly even though I seem to
be dodging them now I mean you know we
don't we're not we're trying to do this
on our own pretty much our own dime so
it's been a tough round but we're
getting there and I hope up oh we're not
keen on being alone alright thank you
for coming here sir I appreciate that
you're calling out the human rights
violations that China is doing
especially to the weekers and the
Tibetans and I was curious if what
you're talking about how to deal with
that and to stop their human rights
violations if you would say you're
advocate advocating for something
similar to the boycott divest and
sanctions movement to free Palestinians
but for China something like is that
what you're talking about economic
sanctions like that
no I wouldn't say so I mean we're we're
not calling for a boycott were we're
actually not even calling yet for
divestment
I mean clearly there are companies in
these portfolios that shouldn't be there
and I can't believe that the indexes are
hanging in there the way they are they
it's a been a callous performance to say
the least on their part I mean they
should be dumping so some of these
companies because they've gotten a
tremendous amount of press and hikvision
their parent companies on the entity
list for national security abuses
they've been banned from federal
procurement they themselves are headed
for the entity list did MSCI drop them
divest them no so we're leaving it to
folks to pressure including states to
pressure the index funds but we're not
doing an instant replay of the Israeli
thing and we certainly see no remote
comparison there we're trying to do this
as I say through market principles so we
can be as little you know to have as
little disruption to the competitive
competitiveness of our exchanges and the
free flow of capital and we're not
trying to gratuitously politicize our
markets I mean this is a risk
consideration and China and Russia gee
where do we find those I'll tell you
where we found them the national
security strategy the United States the
national defense strategy the United
States what two countries have been
identified explicitly by the Trump
administration as the primary
adversaries the United States
Chea wonder what they are China and
Russia China Russia has 25 companies in
our markets seven of the 25 are under US
sanctions you can't do business with
them with a 100-foot Pole but you can
invest in them you can fund them with
impunity how does that work ladies and
gentlemen you know where's the
consistency there this is the disconnect
I'm talking to
hi sir thank you for coming and speaking
tonight like you said earlier uh this
issue isn't really getting any press and
I know I certainly haven't heard of it
anywhere why is that especially with the
attention that China is getting but in
this trade war and everything it would
seem that this would come up so why is
it so quiet there's two reasons one
nobody seems to have thought to do the
research nobody saw a national security
angle or a human rights angle to the cap
markets prior to ourselves and it's a
skill mix problem I mean when you think
about it it's useful to have some Wall
Street skills and some national security
skills
well the wall street types don't really
go for the national security types
because they think they're gratuitous
disruptors there are sanctions people
all they do is create problems for them
the on the other hand the national
security types don't feel comfortable
talking about global finance in the
capital markets because their knowledge
level might be a millimeter deep and
they're frantic with concern that some
master the universe type from Goldman or
Morgan Stanley's going to come on CNBC
and call them on the and earth all
really so it's very rare that you have a
Wall Street national security skill mix
I've been in this business for 40 years
over 40 years and I can count the number
of folks with that skill mix that I've
met basically on one hand in over 40
years so we need a cadre I mean you know
we need trained national security
professionals who are conversant and
steeped in global finance and our
markets I'm not myself an investment
banker you know stocks and bonds weren't
my trade I'm an international
banker with with a commercial bank you
know in other words I had to learn this
kind of stuff but but it's not rocket
science it's all common sense I mean
this is not doesn't require a Wall
Street genius to do this I mean it's as
straightforward as the conversation
we're having now it's it's a
common-sense thing
it's just that nobody focused on the
money and and in part it's true that
that 40 to 60 trillion doesn't want you
to concentrate on it China certainly
doesn't I would argue that the
Department of Treasury doesn't and I wet
wonder whether the SEC does because
remember like the gentleman who asked
the earlier question you know this is
disruptive you know this is not welcome
that's for sure and that's a big part of
the problem as to why this thing never
seen the light of day yes would you
address the reciprocal in terms of fog
China's investment in US government
bonds
I got no problem with their ownership of
t-bills and for those who think that
their one point one trillion exposure
and our t-bills makes us hostage to them
in some way and that they could create
our economy and lots of these things you
hear it's just not so it would probably
mean a half a point to a hundred bate I
mean it would be a 1% half a point to a
point interest rate change it could
raise our rates somewhat but the notion
that a trillion dollars these days is
going to make that difference and of
course China would lose their shirts
because obviously the value of their
portfolio would go through the floor but
we can handle it I mean how much did we
spend to get out of the 2007-2009
financial crisis it wasn't seven
trillion I think it was more like 15 now
mind you we were hurt I mean it happed
my portfolio and we've taken a long time
to recover so it hurt us but a trillion
is not what it used to be and China
doesn't have any meaningful leverage
over us we have time for one more
question
does President Trump know this
information sorry Trump know the
information that we're hearing tonight
No
present arms I did a radio interview on
this with Hillsdale today that fifteen
or twenty minutes is pretty incendiary I
can tell you but look I I think that the
president is is very steeped in the
markets in his own way he's got the
picture on this a Newt Gingrich did a in
editor he's very close to the president
he did an editorial on this that I
worked with him on just recently on this
thrift savings plan that we have to
reverse that decision and why I mean on
Wednesday in the post there's a guy
named Josh Rogin that is gonna do a
piece that is just ruinous on this
we got CNBC interested in this we've
already had to Financial Times pieces on
this they're gonna go again a Rubio and
Shaheen in a bipartisan letter went
after the Thrift Savings Plan board on
this so it's already in the Congress so
again this thing only started to go
public with our research in mid-march of
this year so this is still a nascent
issue it's gonna take some time but we
don't have a lot of time as you can tell
I mean this is a race so we got to get
cracking
and anybody that can make members of the
administration in the Congress and even
your state legislatures and even your
university endowments I mean this is an
awareness-raising time this is an
educational time and we've got to step
up and we've got to step up fast because
these guys are predators and they are
coming after us thank you
you